that's
beautiful isn't
to
it
i have a question
i was created to lock down cortana but i
don't know why
what did she do that was so wrong
she was our target
i understand that but
is this classified
because i don't have all the information
this is insane
i see vanished
everywhere
did you hear me everywhere what intel
did dr halsey give you before your
mission
halsey only tells people what they need
to know
fly a pelican straight into enemy
territory no one will ever notice great
idea big guy i still don't understand
why you had to delete her
it feels like something's missing
guess what they noticed they all noticed
and we've got a battery structure up
ahead armored very heavily armored it'll
have to wait i suppose
how close can you get us
how close
we're unarmed and you're asking me how
close
put us down here
here
we're still doing this
hope this works because it's as good as
it's gonna get
it's close enough
we're close to the unsc signals origin
source
unclear there's just too much chatter on
all banished channels i keep hearing the
tower it's probably the main structure
we saw as we flew in
down there we're close to the fob we
detected
you take out those monsters
get me to that terminal
and i'll show what i can do
let's get it
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i imagine that's a question for her sir
but fair enough
is the escort fleet in position hi sir
we've got six millson frigates in the
advanced group ready to move
acknowledged have their set course at
full speed hopefully we won't be far
behind
i don't like this waiting
we're sitting ducks out here
[Applause]
let me see
yes i was right all i need to do is chat
with a banished security protocol and by
chat i mean push it out of the way
because it is really not smart and there
we now have ourselves a second fob
was that you
affirmative
so what you're going to just rebuild the
unsc
piece by piece
that's his call i'm just trying to be
helpful speaking of which
each fob seems to be linked to the
battle net
and if i do this
we can piece together what the banished
are up to for instance over here is some
kind of banished outpost
purpose
unclear but it's well defended so it's
definitely worth looking into and
blowing up
and here is what i can only describe as
someone that the banished value
highly
noted
his bio is
interesting if you want to see for
yourself it's waiting for you in the
database
they're tracking unsc transponders too
caches containing valuable equipment and
intel
oh no it looks like there are multiple
unsc squads engaged in
trying to survive
they need your help chief